Donald Trump did end up having a press
briefing yesterday after not having them
over the weekend after the bleach
injection Fiasco led to him just walking
out without taking questions from the
Friday press briefing and it was a
really weird one yesterday first it was
scheduled as normal for 5:00 p.m. as a
White House coronavirus Task Force press
briefing then it was cancelled then very
haphazardly a Rose Garden press
conference was scheduled to replace the
press briefing and to Trump's credit he
did take questions but for whatever
reason there was one question that was
even remotely connected to the bleach
injection Fiasco I've been asking around
whether reporters were warned off of
asking questions about the bleach fiasco
or what but in any case the one question
that was asked was about the number of
disinfectant ingestion related phone
calls to poison control centers across
the country which have increased this
Trump take any responsibility was the
question big shocker
he does not take any responsibility take
a look at the video specifically said
they've seen a spike in people using
disinfectant after your comments last
week I know you said they were sarcastic
I can't imagine why I can't imagine why
yeah take any responsibility on I can't
imagine I can't imagine that yeah go
ahead please president he can't imagine
why well because he wondered aloud what
if we hit the body with an injected
disinfectant just four days ago that's
why the question is being posed to him
and we're now learning of many more
instances of this the reporter there
mentioned Maryland the increase in
Maryland of calls to poison control
related to the ingestion of household
cleaners we also have some news out of
Kansas in Kansas a state health officer
Lee Norman said poison control saw a 40%
increase in cleaning chemical related
cases in the last few days including one
guy who drank a product because someone
suggested it we don't know whether that
someone was Donald Trump someone who
heard it from Donald Trump or just a
mere coincidence and not related to
Donald Trump at all
so here
what I want to ask you about I've been
reading the new defense online from
mostly people on the right but even from
some people on the left kind of agreeing
here and they've been saying if you are
so dumb that you drink bleach because
the president mentions it as a possible
coronavirus treatment you don't deserve
to survive in other words it's a sort of
Darwinian thinning a thinning of the
herd type of thing even though it's it's
obviously not really Darwinian but it's
colloquially named that if you were this
dumb that simply because Trump talks
about drinking bleach you do it that it
is a calling of the week thinning of the
herd sort of thing and that we shouldn't
really worry about it and it reminds me
of this idea that if you want to thin
the herd you get rid of the warning
labels and just let it happen so what do
you think I mean my reaction tends to be
I don't condemn the cond
I condemn the con men so it feels weird
to me just write it writing it off that
way it's not you know but it's not the
job of the president it's not excusable
that a president says things that goad
dumb people if that's what you believe
they are into killing themselves there's
a very sort of utilitarian reaction
which is that a lot of the people aren't
dying they're just getting sick enough
from drinking bleach that they need to
go into the hospital they require
medical services they consume medical
resources and it's taking hospital space
away from people who actually just have
corona virus that would be a very
utilitarian reaction but a lot of people
tweeting me and this seems to be the
predominant reaction the contempt must
be for the con men not for the cond
ignoring the plight of those who are
conned is not particularly progressive
and I agree with that I want to hear
from you bigger picture regardless of
the cond we can objectively say a
president shouldn't be floating such
ideas period regardless of the impact
that they have one other reaction has
been if you only harm yourself then we
should be less concerned it's not even
clear to me that
people who fall for this stuff are only
harming themselves they may be
suggesting other people do it they may
be harming themselves in a way that then
can leave their children without a
parent the idea of only harming yourself
is one that we would have to grapple
with a little more more distinctly
overall though people hope to be able to
trust the office of the presidency until
now many people have been told you can
trust the office of the presidency so
maybe the problem isn't with the people
but with a system that has allowed trust
in the office of the presidency to be so
exploited by a con man like Donald Trump
blaming the frightened masses so to
speak as one person said to me on
Twitter rather than those with the
institutional power doesn't strike me as
progressive and I agree with that but I
want to hear from you one of our
sponsors today is a game called
lawgivers a turn based political
simulation game for PC iOS and Android
if you've ever wanted to start a
political party or run for office or
shape the destiny of our country here's
your chance I've been having a ton of
fun with the game you do get to
experience legislative democracy up
close and the dynamics of the game are
really impressive you make election
promises to your constituents it's up to
you whether you keep those promises when
you're in office all of the laws you
pass affect your country's happiness and
safety healthcare environment you can
abolish laws that are already in place
you can ratify the Constitution you
decide if you want the government to be
a healthy democracy or authoritarian
tyranny you can be corrupt and take
bribes political assassinations are part
of the game it's nuts actually it's a
really good time it doesn't get old
because you'll never play it the same
way twice this is not some cheesy
free-to-play game it's very clear that a
lot of time went into the development it
has very positive reviews on Steam and
in the App Store's four and a half stars
or higher on all platforms go to david
pakman.com slash game which is where you
can watch the trailer download the game
for steam iOS and
Android that's david pakman.com slash
game